Matthew bowling Texas High School
sprinter ran a nine nine eight 100-meter
dash breaking the national high school
record and I think it's straight Jesuit
college prep in Houston Texas hey Matt
good morning how much attention have you
gotten since setting this record good
morning it's been a lot um I was on like
some SportsCenter pages and like meme
pages on Instagram but uh it's been a
lot it's fun your nickname is White
Lightning who gave you that I don't
really know I saw it on like Twitter but
yeah I don't know I think it's just like
a random thing also that do you have a
nickname no I don't well we got to come
up with one if you're gonna run this
fast mad okay I don't know I like doing
other people give me a nickname
okay that's but that's the way Usain
Bolt never had a nickname so maybe you
don't need one maybe maybe you just say
no I don't I don't want one I don't need
one yeah maybe maybe Matt or Matthew now
it's good Matt is really crazy as a
nickname I think you go with that yeah
how would your time stand up to Usain
Bolt in the Olympics um well that time
was I think they said it was a point for
but for the 100-meter that's that's a
decent amount I still got a lot of work
to do but um I mean it feels good
knowing like I have that potential and
if I keep training like I can get to
that Olympic time would you have
qualified for the Olympics with that
time I'm not sure I've ever really
checked that I've seen some like videos
of like comparing us but I never really
checked that now it's wind-aided yes
okay does that diminish this at all a
little bit some people try to make it a
bigger deal than it is on social media
like it there's a +4 wind which means
like it obviously helps a little bit but
I mean it's it's still a good time I'm
still happy with it and hopefully I can
have a meet where the wind is calmer so
I can do it again
yeah but Matt the guys you were going
against had the wind behind them as well
you're not the only one who had wind
behind you yeah and you still they
needed more wind and you still smoke
them thank you the you're a novelty you
know that when you step to the starting
line
what kind of looks do you get or
conversation do you get when you step to
the starting line in the 100-meter dash
I guess like when I get ready in the
blocks sometimes look in the stands and
see people stand up and like get ready
to cheer like take videos which is
really cool it really pushes me and like
knowing that I have people who want to
see me do well helps me to do better but
what about your competitors they say
anything to you they surprised when they
see you walk up to the starting block
not really we're all pretty focused
especially like with track like everyone
gets super serious so nobody people try
not to say anything before the race but
like after like will congratulate each
other when did you know you were fast
well I started in middle school and I
was pretty fast for a middle schooler
but I guess like when I knew like I had
a potential to be like really good was
in high school I started running the 400
which is a little longer distance and I
was running good times my sophomore year
and then I just like kept sticking with
it and kept working are what's it like
to run fast what's that feeling like
that you just had in this race it's
really good
getting up tall in the middle of the
race and just running to your max speed
and then when you cross the line and
wait like five seconds to look at the
time on the board and then you see like
a new PR or like a good time like that
it's just crazy it's a really good
feeling because like you work so hard
since August to get to that point and
it's just like like a moment like it's
really special did you play football I
did in middle school I wasn't very good
but not in high school
wait I just send you on a go pattern I
mean come on yeah I mean they're not a
catch a little bit oh you got a camp you
can run you can catch come on yeah
you're like Forrest Gump though Matthew
I mean I'm just gonna hand you the ball
and you run run Matthew run yeah I can
try that I don't know if it'll work but
I can try
what what is the strategy when you run
thank Jade do you know I remember
talking to Carl Lewis that he knew the
exact number of steps I think it was 44
steps that he knew where he was in those
steps when he was running a race is it
that scientific for you no I can't
really count steps it's just too hard
like it's really fast movements for me
so when I count steps it makes me go a
little bit slower but I guess like just
like muscle repetition my muscle memory
you know like how far like you're
supposed to drive like I'll Drive for
like 30 meters and no it's time to like
get tall and get to my max speed if you
go to you're going to Georgia next year
right yes University of Georgia okay if
Kirby smart says hey Matthew I need some
help
wide receiver on the football team I
don't know it would be hard to decline
that but I don't think that I wasn't
going to do well I'm not that big I'm
like six foot does it matter as fast as
you are if they don't catch you Matthew
it doesn't hurt that is true I don't
know maybe I think about it it would be
great if you just showed up at fall
practice and didn't tell anybody just as
a walk-on and then you just started
running hey congrats on it and good luck
at Georgia and continued success thank
you really appreciate it that's Matthew
bowling High School
ran a 998 when dated though I like the
haters worse a wind-aided
I'm going okay hey anybody can do that
with the wind yeah yeah if you give me
enough wind I could run a 998 for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on VR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app